This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We begin today in Las Vegas, the year 2004, the scene, a high stakes poker game. Our protagonist is a woman named Annie Duke. She's about to win $2 million. I'm all in. And with that top-air fill, Helmut's going all in with his 450,000 chips and he duked put the pressure on Phil and she checked raised him. This was the final hand of the World Series of Poker tournament of champions. They had these incredible Hall of Fame players like Doyle Brunson who was a Hall of Famer, Johnny Chan who was a Hall of Famer and then Phil Helmuth who has the most champion chips
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。今天我们要把时间拨回到2004年的拉斯维加斯，当时正在进行一场高额扑克局。我们的主角是一位名叫安妮·杜克的女性。她即将赢得200万美元。我全压了。随着菲尔·赫尔穆特也全压了他那45万筹码，安妮给菲尔施加了压力，并对他进行了加注反击。这是世界扑克大赛冠军赛的决胜局。场上有许多传奇的名人堂玩家，比如身为名人堂成员的多伊尔·布朗森，身为名人堂成员的强尼·陈，还有拥有世界扑克大赛历史上最多冠军头衔的菲尔·赫尔穆特，
of anyone in the history of the World Series of Poker and then there was me. And he calls you all in and Phil sees what he's up against. Annie and this guy Phil were the last two at the table and Annie has overcome with emotion seeing how close she is to winning this championship. Annie's crying, Phil standing up, pacing back and forth, the dealers laying out the cards that will determine who wins. Annie has control of his hand.
以及我。然后他选择跟注，菲尔看清了自己的对手。安妮和这个名叫菲尔的家伙是桌上仅存的最后两人，看到自己离赢得这个冠军如此之近，安妮激动得难以自制。安妮在哭泣，菲尔站起身来，来回踱步，荷官正在发牌，这张牌将决定谁能获胜。安妮掌控着这手牌。
Now here comes the turn. It's a seven. No help for Phil. Annie was the only woman in this competition. She had knocked out eight guys, eight of the best players in the world, to get to this point. Annie, Duke, is now what card away from $2 million? But I didn't really feel like I deserve to be at that table. At that moment, Annie Duke was feeling the pressure of something that psychologists call stereotype threat.
现在转牌来了。是一张7。对菲尔没有任何帮助。安妮是这场比赛中唯一的女性。为了走到这一步，她淘汰了八名男选手，八名世界上最优秀的牌手。安妮·杜克现在距离200万美元只差一张牌了吗？但当时的我并不觉得自己配得上坐在那张桌子旁。在那一刻，安妮·杜克感受到了心理学家所说的“刻板印象威胁”所带来的压力。
Here's how it works. Let's say you think people have a certain stereotype about you. There's a part of you that's afraid that your actions and behavior will prove the stereotype is true. I'm sort of thinking about, well, if I fold and I'm wrong, everybody's going to be like, see, she plays like a girl, like, look how he pushed her around. But Annie's story is also about a second girl, like look how he pushed her around. But any story is also about a second idea. One that often has a positive outcome. This idea is called stereotype tax. That's when a stereotype that others have about you works to your advantage.
它的运作机制是这样的。假设你认为别人对你抱有某种刻板印象。你的内心深处会有一种恐惧，害怕自己的言行会坐实这种刻板印象。我当时心里在想，好吧，如果我弃牌而且我猜错了，所有人都会觉得：看吧，她打起牌来就像个女人，瞧瞧她是怎么被别人牵着鼻子走的。但安妮的故事也关乎第二个观点，就像瞧瞧她是怎么被别人牵着鼻子走的。但安妮的故事也关乎第二个想法。这个想法通常会带来积极的结果。这个想法被称为“刻板印象红利”。也就是当别人对你的刻板印象对你有利时。
If somebody was at the table who was so emotionally invested in the fact that I was a woman, given that they're treating me that way, how can I come up with the best strategy to take their money? Because I guess in the end isn't that the best revenge. Annie had started playing poker in 1994. By the time she got to that championship game 10 years later, she had basically figured out how to make stereotypes about women and poker work for her. So I can tell you that the first year that I played in the World Series of Poker main event, which was in 1994, 3% of the entrance were women, and last year that number would have been
如果桌上有人对我是个女性这件事有着强烈的情绪执念，既然他们用这种方式对待我，我该如何制定出最佳策略来赢走他们的钱？因为我想，到头来这不就是最好的复仇吗？安妮是在1994年开始打扑克的。十年后，当她进入那场冠军赛时，她基本上已经摸透了如何利用女性和扑克牌的刻板印象来为自己服务。所以我可以告诉你，我参加世界扑克大赛主赛事的头一年，也就是1994年，参赛者中只有3%是女性，而去年的这个数字大概是
the same. Wow, so this is an extraordinarily male-dominated sport. Completely. I was generally the only woman at the table. I had to really love that game in order to be willing to expose myself to a lot of the behavior that I was experiencing. Tell me what you heard. What did people say?
一样的。哇，所以这是一个极度男性主导的运动。完全是的。我通常是桌上唯一的女性。我必须深爱这项游戏，才能甘愿承受我当时所经历的种种行为。告诉我你都听到了什么。人们都说了些什么？
There were people who were incredibly welcoming. There were other people. There was one guy who I lost a pot to and he said, don't cry, I'll give you your money back if we go across the street to the Northern. And the Northern was a hotel. Wow. You know, and I got called a lot of bad things. But to think about it as, okay, given that this person is viewing me in a way that I find disrespectful,
有些人表现得极其热情。但也有其他人。曾有一个家伙，我输给他一局之后，他说：别哭，如果你愿意去街对面的北方酒店，我把钱还给你。北方酒店是一家酒店。哇。你知道的，而且我听到了很多难听的骂声。但如果你这样想：好吧，既然这个人看待我的方式让我觉得不被尊重，
try to separate yourself from your emotional reaction to that and think about how you can use that to your advantage. Annie had learned to make her opponents pay, literally pay for the stereotypes they held about women. Right. At the poker table, for example, I sort of in my head divided people into three categories. One was the flirting showvonist and that person was really viewing me in a way that was sexual. And not as blatantly as the guy who invited her back to the great Northern Hotel.
那就试着把你自己对这种情绪反应剥离开来，想想该如何利用这一点来为你所用。安妮已经学会了让她的对手付出代价，字面意义上让他们为自己对女性的刻板印象付出代价。没错。比方说，在扑克桌上，我在脑海里把人分成了三类。其中一类是调情式大男子主义者，这个人看待我的方式带有明显的性暗示。而且不像那个邀请她回伟大北方酒店的家伙那么露骨。
These were just guys who sometimes seem more concerned about getting Annie to like them than they were about winning. They'd show me their whole cards when they were done with the hand to show me whether it was a good fold or not. They'd kind of tell me during the hand if I was alone with them in the hand, you know, what they had.
这群人只是有时候看起来比起赢得比赛，更在乎怎么让安妮喜欢他们。他们会在打完一手牌后把底牌亮给我看，以此向我展示这算不算是明智的弃牌。如果这手牌只有我和他单独对垒，他们甚至会在过程中告诉我，你知道的，他们拿的是什么牌。
They were trying to make nice with you. They were trying to make nice with me. Exactly. I never did go out on a date with any of them, but, you know, it was kind of flirtatious at the table and I could use that to my advantage. Then there's a second kind of guy. What I would call the disrespecting show of anist, who mainly just thought that
他们试图对你示好。他们试图对我示好。没错。我当然从来没有跟他们中的任何一个人约会过，但是，你知道的，桌上的气氛有点像在调情，而我可以利用这一点来为我所用。接着是第二类人。我称之为不尊重女性的大男子主义者，他们主要觉得
women weren't creative, that they could only think one level deep. So they didn't believe that you knew how to bluff, for example, because that's a level deep in your thinking. They didn't think that you really had creativity. They thought you were very straightforward in the way that you play, because you know, you're a girl. Right, so they assume that you're naive creativity, they thought you were very straightforward in the way that you play, because you know you're a girl. Right, so they assume that you're naive, basically. Exactly. So there are strategies that you can use against them, mainly you can bluff those people a lot.
女人没有什么创造力，思考问题只能停留在表面的一层。所以他们不相信你知道如何诈唬，比方说，因为那需要更深一层的思考。他们不认为你真的有创造力。他们觉得你打牌的方式非常直来直去，因为你知道的，你是个小姑娘。没错，所以他们基本上假设你很天真，觉得你没有创造力，他们认为你打牌的方式非常直来直去，因为你知道你是个女孩。没错，所以他们基本上假设你很天真。完全正确。所以你可以对付他们使用一些策略，主要是你可以狠狠地诈唬这些人。
And then there's a third kind of guy, perhaps the most reckless. The angry show of an ass. This is a guy who would do anything to avoid being beaten by a woman. You couldn't bluff them because they would call you all the time for fear that you might be bluffing them. And then they would also try to push you around a lot. So they would play extremely aggressively against you. They'd be trying to bluff you all the time.
然后还有第三种人，或许也是最鲁莽的一种。愤怒的大男子主义者。这种人会为了避免输给一个女人而做出任何事。你无法诈唬他们，因为他们会随时跟你的注，生怕你其实是在诈唬他们。而且他们还会试图处处挤兑你。所以他们会对你采取极具侵略性的打法。他们会时刻试图对你进行诈唬。
Because the best thing that could happen to them was that they bluffed you and then they could show you that they had a terrible hand and be like, ha ha, little girl, look what happened to you. Right, because that would confirm that everything that they believed about you was true. Right. So you can just sort of wait until they, what I say is, until they would impale themselves on your chips. I have to ask you though, so it's clear that thinking about this mathematically and in a very detached and unemotional way gave you an edge at the poker table and I can clearly
因为对他们来说最棒的事情就是，他们成功诈唬了你，然后向你展示他们其实拿了一手烂牌，并说道：哈哈，小丫头，看你落得什么下场。没错，因为那会证实他们关于你的一切信念都是正确的。没错。所以你只需要等着他们，用我的话来说，直到他们自己一头撞死在你的筹码上。不过我得问你，显然，用数学的、极其超然且冷静的方式来思考，确实为你在扑克桌上提供了优势，我也完全
see how that's very smart. But you're not a robot, you're not a computer. At some level you also are processing how people actually are behaving toward you. And I'm wondering if you could talk a minute about how this felt. Most of the time I would sort of say I have emotions about this, I'm going to set them talk a minute about how this felt. Most of the time, I would sort of say, I have emotions about this, I'm going to set them aside and deal with them later. And then I would leave the table and drive home in tears.
能理解这有多么聪明。但你不是机器人，你不是计算机。在某种程度上，你也在处理别人实际上是如何对待你的。我想知道你能不能谈谈这种感觉是怎样的。大多数时候，我通常会对自己说：我对这事有情绪，但我打算把它们放在一边，等下再去处理。然后我就会离开牌桌，一路哭着开车回家。
In her first 10 years of the poker table, Annie was able to compartmentalize her emotions, and she won a lot of money doing this, using stereotype tax to her advantage. That was until 2004 at the Tournament of Champions. Intimidation is such a big part of being a successful player. Is that going to come into play at this table, you think? Not really. In fact, these players know each other so well. If one of them sneezes, somebody else has already handed them a handkerchief. Actually, at least for Annie, that wasn't true.
在扑克桌上的前十年里，安妮能够将自己的情绪进行心理隔离，她通过这种方式赢得了大量的钱，并成功利用了刻板印象红利。直到2004年的冠军赛。恐吓是成为一名成功牌手的极重要一部分。你觉得这会在今天的牌桌上发挥作用吗？其实不会。事实上，这些选手彼此太熟悉了。如果其中一个人打了个喷嚏，另一个人早就递上手帕了。其实，至少对安妮来说，事实并非如此。
She had never played poker on TV before, and she was pretty sure she had been invited as the token woman, that she was way out of her league. She thought that ESPN, televised in the game in this way for the first time, just thought it was good optics to have her there. And I went in there with this incredible fear that my play, which was now in front of lipstick cameras, so my mistakes were no longer going to be private to me, that that was going to expose that everybody was right, and I was actually a terrible player,
她以前从来没有上过电视打扑克，而且她很确信自己受邀只是为了充当女性代表，觉得自己根本不在同一个水平线上。她认为ESPN首次以这种方式转播比赛，只是觉得现场有她在画面上会很好看。我带着一种巨大的恐惧走上赛场，害怕我的牌局现在正暴露在特写摄像机前，这意味着我犯的错误将不再属于我个人私密，这会暴露所有人的看法都是对的，其实我是一个糟糕的牌手，
and despite the fact that I had spent the last 10 years making my living playing poker at the highest levels of the game, that I didn't really deserve to have ever won anything I was bad and I had just gotten lucky. And now everybody was going to know it and what they were saying was true. You felt like an imposter. Completely.
尽管我过去十年一直靠在扑克最高水平的赛事中谋生，但我其实根本不配赢得过任何东西，我很烂，我只是运气好罢了。现在所有人都会知道这一点，而且他们说的话都是真的。你觉得自己是个冒名顶替者。完全是这样。
You were facing a very difficult situation here, which is you're not just juggling with what's happening at the poker table, but you're juggling with all this other psychological crap in a way that just makes it hard to focus on what it is that you're actually doing. And in so many ways, that not to me is a perfect illustration of stereotype threat. It shows that when there's a stereotype that's in the air, when there's a stereotype that multiple people believe, even if you don't believe it yourself. If you're the person who is potentially at the receiving end of that stereotype, it affects
你当时面临着一个非常艰难的处境，那就是你不仅要应付扑克桌上正在发生的事情，还要应付所有这些其他的心理垃圾，这让你很难专注于你实际上正在做的事情。从很多方面来看，这对我来说就是刻板印象威胁的一个完美例证。它表明，当空气中弥漫着一种刻板印象时，当一种有多人深信不疑的刻板印象存在时，即使你自己并不相信它。如果你是那个潜在的刻板印象接受者，它就会影响
your behavior in such a way that you become more likely to make the stereotype come true. I think that that's completely true. It was always in the back of my mind, like, that, do they really respect me? Why are they talking to me? Is it just because they are thinking about me in a different way? Like they want to be friends with me because I'm a girl or do they really respect me? Why are they talking to me? Is it just because they are thinking about me in a different way? Like they want to be friends with me because I'm a girl or do they actually respect my play? There was one hand, Annie says, when stereotype threat got the better of her.
你的行为，让你更有可能把这个刻板印象变成现实。我觉得这完全正确。它一直萦绕在我的脑海里，比如，他们真的尊重我吗？他们为什么要跟我说话？是不是因为他们用一种不同的眼光看待我？就像他们想跟我交朋友是因为我是个女孩，还是他们真的尊重我？他们为什么要跟我说话？是不是因为他们用一种不同的眼光看待我？就像他们想跟我交朋友是因为我是个女孩，还是他们真的尊重我的牌技？安妮说，有那么一手牌，刻板印象威胁最终占了上风。
So in this particular hand where I had two tens, which is a pretty good hand, it was good enough that there wasn't a huge chance that her opponent, this guy Greg Raymer, had a better hand. But there was still a chance. As a professional poker player, this is the kind of hand that you evaluate in a matter of seconds. So I really needed to eliminate that hand as a possibility and I was having a lot of trouble doing that because I was so afraid of hand as a possibility and I was having a lot of trouble doing that because I was so afraid of making this really bad big decision on television and having everyone say I told you so. This was a pivotal hand, but a lot of the significance was really just in Annie's head. If she folded but really had the best hand, everybody's going to be like, see she plays like a girl,
所以在这一手特定的牌局中，我拿了两张10，这是一手相当不错的牌，好到她的对手——这个叫格雷格·雷默的家伙——手牌比她好的概率并不算特别大。但仍然有这种可能。作为一名职业扑克牌手，这是你需要在几秒钟内评估的那种牌。所以我真的需要排除那种牌的可能性，而我在这方面遇到了很大困难，因为我太害怕
like look how he pushed her around. And if I called and I was wrong, then I could come up with a whole other thing, like look how bad she could, didn't she know that he had the best hand, like any idiot would have known that, you know, and that was running in my head as I was trying to make this decision. So you're down to if you do and you're down to if you don't? Absolutely, absolutely. And it was incredibly difficult and it wasn't until I kind of Absolutely, absolutely. And it was incredibly difficult and it wasn't until I kind of snapped to and saw this tell that he had. And you see a tell you mean what? So a tell is a physical, well it could be something verbal that somebody says that gives a clue,
在电视上做出这种非常糟糕的重大决定，并让所有人说“我早就告诉过你了”。这是一手关键牌，但其中很大一部分重要性其实只存在于安妮的脑海里。如果她弃牌但实际上她拿的是最好的牌，所有人都会觉得：看吧，她打起牌来就像个女孩，瞧瞧她是怎么被别人牵着鼻子走的。如果我跟注而我猜错了，那我就会招致另一堆说辞，比如看看她有多蠢，难道她不知道对方拿了更大的牌吗？任何白痴都该看出来，你知道的，当我试图做出这个决定时，这些想法一直在我的脑海里盘旋。所以你进退维谷，怎么做都不对？绝对是这样，绝对是这样。而且这极其困难，直到我某种程度上
but generally when we talk about tells we're talking about something physical that somebody does, that telegraphs the quality of their hand or at least what they think the quality of their hand is. So Greg Raymer did something which I haven't actually said what he actually did because I think that's unfair to him. But he did something that gave away the fact that his hand was very, very strong, which allowed me to then fold. And at that moment I was actually quite confident in it. But Annie's confidence in her decision was short-lived.
猛然清醒过来，发现了他的一个马脚。你看到一个马脚，这是什么意思？所以马脚指的是一个人的肢体动作，当然也可能是某人说的话中泄露出的线索，但通常当我们谈论马脚时，我们指的是某人做出的某种肢体动作，它泄露了他们手牌的质量，或者至少泄露了他们认为自己手牌质量如何的信息。所以格雷格·雷默做了一件事——我实际上没有说他具体做了什么，因为我觉得这对不公平。但他做出的某个举动暴露了一个事实，即他的手牌非常非常强，这让我得以选择弃牌。而那一刻我其实对此相当自信。但安妮对这个决定的自信并没有持续多久。
Another player came up to her during a break in the game. What he said, kicked the stereotype threat and Annie's head into overdrive. Phil Helmuth, right after that hand occurred, came up and just told me like what an idiot I was because Clearly Greg Raymer had Ace King and I thought oh my gosh This is a guy who's like at the now. I think he's a 12-time world champion But at the time he probably had you know seven world championships or something and he seemed pretty confident that he had Ace King and oh no, and it was just and and then I had an hour in my room having a panic attack Well, we were on break from the tournament. It was pretty awful head ace king and oh no, and it was just and and then I had an hour in my room having a panic attack.
比赛中场休息时，另一名选手走了过来。他说的话，让刻板印象威胁和安妮脑海中的焦虑瞬间飙升到了极致。菲尔·赫尔穆特，就在那手牌打完后不久，走过来告诉我我有多么愚蠢，因为很明显格雷格·雷默拿的是A-K，而我想，哦天哪，这是一个现在——我觉得他是12届世界冠军——但在当时他可能已经赢得了7次世界冠军什么的，而且他看起来非常确信自己拿的是A-K，哦不，这简直是……然后我在房间里度过了一个小时的恐慌发作期。好吧，当时我们正在比赛中途休息。那感觉真是糟透了，他拿的是A-K，哦不，这简直是……然后我在房间里度过了一个小时的恐慌发作期。
Well we were on break from the tournament. It was pretty awful. Stereotype threat had produced in Annie's head what poker players called tilt. Tilt when you allow kind of bad things that happen to you that very often are out of your control to cause you to be a poor decision maker going forward. Annie has picked up a heart draw here. of your control to cause you to be a poor decision maker going forward. So after she nearly lost it in her hotel room, Annie comes back to the table and she has a stroke of luck. She wins a pretty nice hand. And you can actually hear her at this point in the game, Annie begins to loosen up.
好吧，我们当时正在比赛中途休息。那感觉真是糟透了。刻板印象威胁在安妮的脑海里引发了扑克牌手们所说的“情绪失控”（tilt）。所谓“情绪失控”，就是指当你允许那些发生在你身上、往往不受你控制的糟糕事情，导致你在接下来的决策中表现糟糕。安妮在这里抽到了一张红桃听牌。不受你控制的事情，导致你在接下来的决策中表现糟糕。所以在她在酒店房间里情绪几乎崩溃之后，安妮回到了牌桌旁，并且迎来了一点好运。她赢下了一手相当不错的牌。事实上，你甚至可以听到，在比赛的这个阶段，安妮开始放松下来。
It was as if she'd finally gotten the stereotype threat under control. The flop was just wow. Yeah, it doesn't matter what order they come in, right? It doesn't matter. Well, it kind of does in that situation, you know. Annie had turned on the charm. The next time she faced Greg Raymer in a hand, now Raymer needs to call or get out of the way. He got cocky.
就好像她终于把刻板印象威胁控制住了。翻牌简直绝了。对，不管它们以什么顺序出现都无所谓，对吧？无所谓的。嗯，在这种情况下其实还是有差别的，你知道的。安妮开启了她的魅力攻势。下一次她在牌局中面对格雷格·雷默时，这次轮到雷默需要跟注还是退出了。他变得傲慢自大了。
I call. Well, the world champion is going to call. It's a three no good for Raymer. On the next hand, Annie would knock out Raymer, whose nickname was Fossilman. It is an ace, it's no help to Fossilman and he goes down. He played really well. Just like that, Annie was back in the zone. And that actually sort of brought me out of this very bad headspace.
我跟注。好吧，世界冠军要跟注了。一张3，对雷默没有帮助。在下一手牌中，雷默被安妮淘汰了，他的绰号叫“化石人”（Fossilman）。是一张A，对化石人没有任何帮助，他出局了。他打得真的很好。就这样，安妮重新找回了状态。而这其实在某种程度上把我从那种非常糟糕的精神状态中拉了出来。
Soon, the table dwindled to four players. Helm is knocking out Johnny Chan in fourth place. Then there were three. It's a three and that's the end of the line for Howard Letterman. Until finally, Annie and Phil Helmuth, the guy who newly destroyed her confidence earlier in the game, these are the only two left. And Annie says to him,
很快，牌桌上只剩下四名选手。赫尔穆特淘汰了获得第四名的强尼·陈。接着只剩三人。是一张3，霍华德·莱特曼的征程到此为止了。直到最后，安妮和菲尔·赫尔穆特——就是那个不久前在比赛中击碎了她自信心的家伙——成为了仅存的两人。安妮对他说：
This is alright, you know, I'm just happy to be in the final two, I mean, seriously, I don't my money off in the first two hours. You could argue that this little old me act, somehow, really did a number on Phil Helmuth, because for the next half a dozen hands, he just did not know what to make of Annie. And he's got Phil second guessing every movie makes and every movie doesn't make. At this point, it's obvious to both Annie and Phil the other person has a strong hand. The question is, how strong? That's a judgement call.
这挺好的，你知道的，我很高兴能进入最后两人，我是说，说真的，我可没在前两个小时就把钱输光。你完全可以说，这种“我只是个弱女子”的把戏，不知怎么地，真的把菲尔·赫尔穆特给唬住了，因为在接下来的好几手牌里，他根本不知道该怎么应对安妮。菲尔对自己的每一次出牌和弃牌都开始产生怀疑。到了这个时候，安妮和菲尔都很清楚对方手里有一手强牌。问题在于，到底有多强？这是一个需要凭直觉判断的问题。
It's based on probability, instinct, and all the undercurrents, expectations, and stereotypes that have been running through the game the entire time. But now, there's only one question. If anythings that Phil has misjudged her, she knows she should call his bet. And call. Annie calls the all-in! And Phil sees what he's up against. And what he's up against here, meaning the dealer's cards. That's going to determine who wins. And if there was any moment that perfectly revealed
它基于概率、直觉，以及贯穿整场比赛的所有暗流、期待和刻板印象。但现在，只剩下一个问题。如果安妮认为菲尔对她做出了误判，她就知道自己应该跟注他的下注。跟注。安妮选择全压跟注！而菲尔看清了自己的对手。这里的对手指的是荷官发出的牌。那将决定谁能获胜。如果说有哪个瞬间能完美地揭示
how much of an outsider Annie was in this situation, it's this next one. Annie Duke is now one card away from $2 million. In 8, please. Phil Helmuth needs an 8 to win this pot. Both players on their feet anticipating the river card. It's a 3. Annie Duke has defeated 9 of the strongest poker players in the world
安妮在当时的处境中是多么格格不入的话，那就是接下来这个瞬间。安妮·杜克现在距离200万美元只差一张牌。请发一张8。菲尔·赫尔穆特需要一张8才能赢得这个底池。两位选手都站起身来，期待着河牌的到来。是一张3。安妮·杜克击败了世界上9位最顶尖的扑克牌手，
and wins the first ever World Series of Poker Tournament of Champions. In classic reality television style, cameras follow Phil as he storms away from the table, out of door, just pacing around, talking to himself. I know she didn't have it all six times. Oh my God, I won! It was a reaction of a man who just got beat. She had to be 30 to 1 to win that.
并赢得了历史上第一届世界扑克大赛冠军赛。带着经典的真人秀风格，摄像机跟随菲尔，只见他气冲冲地离开牌桌，夺门而出，在外面来回踱步，自言自语。我知道她那六次都不是真的有牌。哦天哪，我赢了！这是一个刚刚落败的男人的反应。她当时夺冠的赔率可是30比1啊。
By someone who wasn't supposed to win and maybe even wasn't supposed to be at the table in the first place. But precisely because Annie Duke knew how stereotypes can be both threat and advantage. Well, you heard Phil and he was right and he was definitely a long shot to win this all, but as the only female at the table she is now the last man standing. I have to say, Annie Duke, you're not just a good poker player, but you're clearly a very wise person. Well, so are you, thank you. High stakes poker is one of many domains where women have been forced to be flexible, or
击败他的是一个本来不该赢、甚至一开始或许根本不该坐在那张牌桌上的人。但正因为安妮·杜克深知刻板印象既可以是一种威胁，也可以是一种优势。好吧，你听到了菲尔的话，他说得对，他当时夺冠的几率确实很低，但作为桌上唯一的女性，她现在成了笑到最后的人。我必须说，安妮·杜克，你不仅是个出色的扑克牌手，显然还是个非常聪明的人。好吧，你也是，谢谢你。高额扑克只是女性被迫保持灵活的众多领域之一，或者
in some cases, to elbow their way into a world dominated by men. For centuries, women have been locked out of different professions because of barriers built on sexism and patriarchy. But as the economy has started to boom and feels traditionally dominated by women, men have not saw jobs in those areas. If anything, they seem to actively avoid such professions. With women are attracted to the occupation, then it becomes something that women do and men would perhaps hesitate to enter.
在某些情况下，是在男性主导的世界里用胳膊肘挤出一席之地。几个世纪以来，由于建立在性别歧视和父权制之上的壁垒，女性一直被挡在许多不同行业之外。但是，随着经济开始腾飞，那些传统上由女性主导的领域，男性并没有去寻找那些岗位。如果有的话，他们似乎还在刻意回避这些职业。如果女性被某个职业吸引，那么它就会变成女性从事的工作，而男性可能会对进入其中犹豫不决。
This is Northwestern University Psychologist Alice Eglie. She says men even avoid female-dominated professions that used to be male-dominated, like working as a bank teller. There used to be quite a few males, but then there got to be so many women out of town. That man could find a bit of a masculinity threat. Oh, you're a bank teller, people would say. They see bank tellers being women, and so they think of it.
这位是西北大学的心理学家爱丽丝·伊格利。她说，男性甚至会回避那些曾经由男性主导、但如今变成由女性主导的职业，比如银行柜员。过去有相当多的男性，但后来城里涌现出了那么多的女性。这可能会让男性感受到某种男子气概受到威胁。人们会说：“哦，你是个银行柜员啊。”他们看到银行柜员都是女性，于是就会这么认为。
Oh, it's feminine, not even knowing much about what they do. After the break, masculinity threats. Man up. You must be gay. How a fear of appearing feminine shapes the lives of men and affects us all. Man up. Kind of girl, isn't it? You're gay.
哦，那是女性化的工作，甚至对他们具体做什么并不了解。休息过后，男子气概受到的威胁。拿出点男子气概来。你一定是同性恋。对于显得女性化的恐惧是如何塑造男性的生活并影响我们所有人的。拿出点男子气概来。像个女孩，不是吗？你是同性恋。
A woman's job. Man up. A woman's job. This is NPR. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. My name is Robert Vaan. When he was 23, Robert Vaan faced a dilemma, conformed to norms of masculinity or pursue a
女人的工作。拿出点男子气概来。女人的工作。这里是NPR。这里是NPR。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我叫罗伯特·范。23岁时，罗伯特·范面临着一个两难抉择：是顺从男子气概的社会规范，还是去追求一个
promising career in a field long dominated by women. His life illustrates how such norms exert a gravitational force on the choices of millions of men. Robert grew up in Belprey, Ohio. Very small town on the border of West Virginia. There were clear expectations for the men in Belprey. Military service was big in my community. For boys who were Robert's age, the extracurricular activity of choice was scouting. My parents were divorced when I was two.
长期由女性主导、但前景光明的职业。他的人生生动地展现了这种规范如何对数百万男性的选择施加一种重力般的引力。罗伯特在俄亥俄州的贝尔普雷长大。那是西弗吉尼亚州边境的一个非常小的镇子。对于贝尔普雷的男性有着明确的期望。参军服役在我的社区里非常普遍。对于罗伯特这个年纪的男孩来说，首选的课外活动是童子军。我两岁时父母就离婚了。
And I didn't really have a father figure growing up and so scouting became a way of getting bond with other men. A few years into scouting, Robert desperately wanted to go on a trip to New Mexico. I grew up in a very poor home, you know, we were on welfare, we didn't have the money to afford such a trip and one of the men in our group actually stepped forward and paid for my way to be able to go. So that was really impactful for me to have one of the men in our troop that saw me enough as a a son or at least someone he took under his wing to say, you know what, this is important, it's a good life experience and I'm going to take the financial hit to make this opportunity
在我成长过程中，我其实并没有真正感受到父爱，所以童子军成了与其它男性建立羁绊的一种方式。加入童子军几年后，罗伯特极度渴望去新墨西哥州旅行。我是在一个非常贫困的家庭长大的，你知道的，我们靠救济金过活，我们没有钱承担这样的旅行，而我们团队中的一位男士实际上站出来，为我支付了成行的费用。所以这对我产生了非常深远的影响，我们队里的一位男士把我当成儿子来看待，或者至少把我当成他羽翼下庇护的人，对我说：“你知道吗，这很重要，这是一次很好的生活体验，我愿意承担经济上的损失，为你创造这个机会。”
for you. Robert loved everything about the trip. You're just doing guy things. It's amazing where you're building campfires and you're putting iodine and water and you're smelling the ponderosa pine trees and you're seeing deer and bears and having to put your food in bear bags and you're just being rowdy and wrestling. It's a great time. When Robby graduated from Bellbury High School in 2002, his plan was to go to college, but he couldn't afford it. I actually did not know about student loans.
罗伯特喜欢这次旅行中的一切。你只是在做男人们做的事。太奇妙了，你在那里搭营火，在水里放碘片，闻着黄松树的芳香，看到鹿和熊，不得不把食物装进防熊袋里，你只是在胡闹、摔跤。那是一段美好的时光。2002年，当罗比从贝尔普雷高中毕业时，他的计划是上大学，但他负担不起学费。我其实并不知道有学生贷款这回事。
I thought you just had to pay out a pocket and I was like, I don't have that kind of money. And so my opportunities were either go get some working class job in my town, working manufacturing at a plant or join the military. He chose the latter. He enlisted in the Navy. One of the things they asked me was Where do you want to have your first duty station? I said I want to be as far away from Ohio as possible And they said how does Sandy go sound? I mean, I said that sounds good
我以为你只能自掏腰包，当时我想：我可没有那种钱。所以我的机会要么是去镇上找一份工人阶级的工作，在工厂里搞制造，要么就是参军。他选择了后者。他应征加入了海军。他们问我的问题之一是：你希望你的第一个服役地点在哪里？我说我希望离俄亥俄州越远越好。他们说圣迭戈听起来怎么样？我的意思是，我说听起来不错。
His first job out at sea was an aviation boson's mates handler. Long job title paired with equally long work hours. 18 hour days we would get the aircraft from the flight deck and we would tax them down to the hangar bay and Chacam and Chainam and do that and so we'd have these long flight days of bringing aircraft down from maintenance. Robert Lightworking those long hours, living on a ship, was like an extended scouting trip. Out to see, there's literally nothing else to do.
他在海上的第一份工作是航空军需长助理（AVCM handler）。一个很长的职位名称，伴随着同样长的工作时间。每天18小时的工作时长，我们要把飞机从飞行甲板上弄下来，然后把它们牵引到机库里，用卡车拉、用链条固定，周而复始，所以我们会有漫长的飞行日，把飞机从维护中接引下来。罗伯特喜欢这种长时间的工作，住在船上就像是一场漫长的童子军旅行。在公海上，字面意义上没有什么别的事情可做。
You are living your life with these people 24-7 and so the downtime for us became sitting around and talking crap to each other and wrestling. So we'd be in our break room pretty much just having full-on group wrestling sessions to get out to energy and then they'd say, okay, we got some flights that are coming in, we got to bring them down. And so you're just doing that all day, so it's just your whole life is around doing your job. Robert joined the military because he didn't have the money for college.
你24小时全天候与这些人共同生活，所以对我们来说，休息时间就是坐在一起互相开玩笑、互相对骂和摔跤。所以我们基本上就是在休息室里进行全方位的团体摔跤训练来宣泄精力，接着他们会说：“好了，有几架飞机要降落了，我们得把它们弄下来。”所以你一整天都在做这些事，你的整个生活就是围绕着你的工作展开的。罗伯特参军是因为他没有上大学的钱。
But after four years of service, he qualified for the GI Bill, which would cover his tuition and living expenses. In 2007 when he was 23, I got out of the military and my wife became the primary breadwinner force. He began thinking about schools and programs. His wife's father had a suggestion. My father-in-law who's a respiratory therapist My father-in-law who is a respiratory therapist said, hey, you know, you should really look into nursing. A man encouraging his daughter's husband to become a nurse. If you see in the movie, meet the parents, you know this is the exact opposite of the relationship portrayed by Ben Stiller and Robert De Niro.
但在服役四年后，他获得了《退伍军人权利法案》的资助，该法案将支付他的学费和生活费。2007年，当他23岁时，我退伍了，我的妻子成了家里的主要经济支柱。他开始考虑学校和专业。他妻子的父亲提出了一个建议。我的岳父是一名呼吸治疗师。
You know Greg's in medicine too, Larry. Oh really? What feeling? Nursing. That's good. No really. What feeling? Nursing.
我的岳父是一名呼吸治疗师，他说：“嘿，你知道的，你真的应该考虑一下护理专业。”一个父亲鼓励女儿的丈夫去当护士。如果你看过电影《拜见岳父大人》，你就会知道这与本·斯蒂勒和罗伯特·德尼罗所刻画的关系完全相反。
The first thing to win through my head was, well, that's a woman's job, that's a female job that's not something that really men go into. We know how this works. Remember psychologists, Alice Eglie? With women are attracted to the occupation, then it becomes something that women do and men would perhaps hesitate to enter. Why is this? What explains the reluctance of many men to enter professions that are dominated by women? Psychologist Jennifer Boston used to believe there was a straightforward answer to that question. Her mother taught her at a very young age
你知道格雷格也从事医学工作，拉里。哦，真的吗？什么领域？护理学。那挺好的。不，真的。什么领域？护理学。
about sexism and misogyny. I was raised by a mother who was going through her own feminist awakening in the 70s and 80s. So by the time I got to college, I kind of, feminism was familiar to me. I had read a lot about it. So for me, college wasn't about kind of realizing that the world is unfair toward women. Instead, college was when she began to realize how the world restricted the choices of men. Freshmanier, Jennifer lived in a co-edorm. She made a whole suite of new friends, both men and women. And so I remember one time I had a crush on this guy and I thought he was really just the cutest thing.
我脑子里闪过的第一件事是：嗯，那是女人的工作，那是女性的工作，那不是男人通常会涉足的领域。我们都知道这是怎么回事。还记得心理学家爱丽丝·伊格利吗？当女性被某个职业吸引时，它就会变成女性从事的工作，而男性可能会对进入其中犹豫不决。这是为什么呢？是什么解释了许多男性不愿进入由女性主导的职业的心理？心理学家詹妮弗·波斯顿过去曾相信这个问题有一个简单的答案。她的母亲在很小的时候就教导她
And I asked a friend of mine, a male friend, don't you think I'm going to change his name? I'm going to call him Dave. Don't you think Dave is really cute? Am I friend? Um, I should have changed his name. And um, my friend Mark, let's call him, said, I don't know, I can't tell. And I was like, what do you mean you can't tell if Dave is cute? Look at him, look at his face, he's call him, said, I don't know, I can't tell. And I was like, what do you mean you can't tell if David's cute?
关于性别歧视和厌女症的知识。我是由一位在70和80年代经历过自身女性主义觉醒的母亲抚养长大的。所以等我上大学时，女权主义对我来说已经不陌生了。我已经读过很多关于它的书。所以对我来说，上大学并不是去意识到世界对女性不公。相反，正是在大学里，她开始意识到世界是如何限制男性的选择的。大一的时候，詹妮弗住在男女混住的宿舍里。她结识了一整套新朋友，有男有女。所以记得有一次我对一个男生产生了好感，我觉得他简直可爱极了。
Look at him, look at his face, he's super cute. And Mark insisted that because he was a man and a straight man, he was incapable of judging the attractiveness of other men. And that enraged me at the time. I thought it was ridiculous. And I thought that he was just being kind of homophobic. Did you tell your friend, I think you're being homophobic?
我问我的一个朋友，一个男性朋友：你不觉得我要改一下他的名字。我叫他戴夫。你不觉得戴夫真的很可爱吗？我的朋友：呃，我本该改个名字的。还有呃，我的朋友马克——我们暂且这么叫他——说：我不知道，我看不出来。我说：你怎么会看不出来戴夫可不可爱？看看他，看看他的脸，他真的超级可爱。而马克坚信，因为他是一个男人，而且是一个直男，所以他没有能力去评判其他男性的外表吸引力。我当时被气坏了。我觉得这太荒谬了。
I don't remember if I accused him of that. I think what I was more inclined to do was say, nobody's gonna think you're gay. I really just want to know, do you think his face is attractive? Jennifer never got an answer from her friend Mark. I assumed that he knew but just didn't feel comfortable saying. Jennifer's first reaction to this was what her mother had taught her. Guys go out of their way to appear macho because of a combination of homophobia and sexism.
而且我觉得他当时只是有点恐同。你有没有告诉你的朋友：我觉得你在恐同？我不记得我有没有指责过他这一点。我想我当时更倾向于说：没人会觉得你是同性恋。我其实只是想知道，你觉得他的脸有吸引力吗？詹妮弗从来没有从她的朋友马克那里得到答案。我猜他其实知道，只是觉得说出来不自在。詹妮弗对此的第一反应是她母亲教给她的那一套。由于恐同和性别歧视的结合，男人们会不遗余力地表现得极具男子气概。
But over time, Jennifer began to study men's behavior, She is now a psychologist at the University of South Florida. And her data prompted her to a more nuanced conclusion about why men like Mark behave the way they do. In one revealing experiment, her team gathered a group of about 200 men and women and sat them in front of computers. We just kind of let them write for, you know, a few minutes about a time when they violated their gender role in public.
但随着时间的推移，詹妮弗开始研究男性的行为，她现在是南佛罗里达大学的心理学家。她的数据促使她对像马克这样的男性为什么会有这种行为得出了一个更细致入微的结论。在一个具有启发性的实验中，她的团队召集了大约200名男女，让他们坐在电脑前。我们只是让他们花几分钟时间写一写他们曾经在公共场合违背自己性别角色的经历。
Some of the women talked about being called a tomboy. Others mentioned times when they worked in male-dominated fields and were made to feel uncomfortable by co-workers. But men? Men say things like, I wore a pink shirt shirt to work or I held my girlfriend's purse while she ran into the bank Or I ordered a drink at a restaurant and when it came out to me It had a little cocktail umbrella in it and my you know my friends tease me So it's like it's just mundane things like women don't say oh, I wore the wrong shirt
有些女性谈到自己被称为“假小子”。另一些人则提到她们曾在男性主导的领域工作，并因同事的行为而感到不舒服。但男性呢？男人们会说这样的话：“我穿了一件粉红色的衬衫去上班”或者“当女友跑进银行时，我帮她拿了钱包”或者“我在餐厅点了一杯饮料，端上来的时候上面带了一把小鸡尾酒伞，然后我的朋友们就拿这个取笑我”。所以这就像是，这只是一些微不足道的小事，女性才不会说“哎呀，我穿错了衬衫”。
They wore the wrong shirt. Why would men make such a big deal out of trivial things? The familiar explanation is misogyny. But then Jennifer began to think about the different messages that boys receive from a very young age. We've all heard the taunts. Are you a real man? Are they say real man? Or they say, man up. There's a lot of things that are off limits for men. Jennifer's research experiments gradually led her to a new understanding of why
她们穿错了衬衫。为什么男人们要把这些琐事搞得这么大惊小怪？常见的解释是厌女症。但随后詹妮弗开始思考男孩们从小到大收到的各种不同信息。我们都听过那些嘲讽。你算是个真正的男人吗？他们会说“真正的男人”吗？或者他们会说“拿出点男子气概来”。有很多事情对男性来说是禁区。詹妮弗的研究实验逐渐引导她对
men behave the way they do. My collaborators and I argue that the male gender role itself is kind of conceptualized as a more precarious status. So, manhood is something that's hard to earn and easy to lose, relative to womanhood. Manhood is something that is hard to earn and easy to lose. This insight changed the way Jennifer thought about the behavior of her friend Mark. The pressure to not reveal any kinds of non-masculine opinions may have been so profound that it kind of made him feel like he really didn't know. Seeing this way, the driving force here is not misogyny, but fear. Men are defending something that's fragile.
男性的行为动机有了新的理解。我和我的合作者认为，男性的性别角色本身被概念化为一种更具不安全感的地位。因此，相对于女性身份而言，男子气概是一种来之不易、却又极易失去的东西。男子气概是一种来之不易、却又极易失去的东西。这种见解改变了詹妮弗对她朋友马克行为的看法。那种不能暴露任何非阳刚观点的压力可能是如此巨大，以至于让他觉得自己真的“不知道”。从这个角度来看，这里的驱动力不是厌女症，而是恐惧。男人们在捍卫一种脆弱的东西。
In terms of why this would be the case, why would you have one sex essentially have a more limited repertoire or have more policing around its boundaries? Why do women take their femininity for granted in ways that men do not take their masculinity for granted? That's a really hard question to answer, but I think it has to do with how men, their social status is more hierarchically organized than women's is. So men are kind of more interested in or motivated to attain social status, and that kind of then translates into what we propose is kind of a chronic anxiety about their status, and
至于为什么会这样，为什么某一个性别本质上会有更受限制的行为模式，或者其边界周围会有更多的规训？为什么女性会理所当然地展现她们的女性气质，而男性却不会理所当然地展现他们的男子气概？这是一个很难回答的问题，但我认为这与男性的社会地位比女性的社会地位组织得更具等级制有关。因此，男性在某种程度上对获得社会地位更感兴趣、也更有动力，而这进而转化为我们所提出的——对自身地位的一种慢性焦虑，
that translates into a concern about whether one's seen as a real man or not. This chronic anxiety comes through in one of Jennifer's experiments. We have men do a stereotypically feminine task like braiding a mannequin's hair versus in another condition, they braid three strands of thick rope. So we kind of, in both conditions, they're braiding, but in one condition it's very what they're doing is very stereotypically feminine because there's a mannequin head and they're
并且这会转化为一种担忧：担心自己是否被视为一个真正的男人。这种慢性焦虑在詹妮弗的一项实验中表露无遗。我们让男性做一个刻板印象中女性化的任务，比如给一个假人模特编辫子，而在另一个对照组中，他们则是编织三股粗绳。所以我们在两种条件下都在进行编织，但在一种条件下，由于有一个假人模特头部，上面戴着一头长长的金色假发，他们被要求给她编辫子，并且还有需要插在她头发里的小粉红色蝴蝶结，因此他们的所作所为具有非常刻板的女性化特征。
kind of she's got this long blonde wig on and they're asked to braid her hair and there's little pink little both that they're supposed to put in her hair. When you run that test on man and you randomly assign them to either braid hair or braid rope, how do you test what happens next and what do the men do? So, after they do that, oh and also while they're doing the activity, we're videotaping them, so we want it to feel very public to them and we tell them, people are going to later code your videotapes. So it's not just that they're sitting alone in a room doing this. So then we shut off the camera and we say, oh, for the next half of the experiment, we're going to have you do
当你对男性进行这项测试，并随机指派他们去编头发或编绳子时，你是如何测试接下来会发生什么的？男人们又会做什么呢？所以，在他们完成任务之后——哦，顺便说一句，当他们在进行这项活动时，我们在用摄像机录像，所以我们希望这让他们感觉非常公开，并且我们告诉他们：人们稍后会对你们的录像进行编码。所以他们不是独自坐在房间里默默无闻地做这件事。接着我们关掉摄像机，说道：“哦，在实验的下一半，我们将让你们做另一项活动，但这一次你们可以自己选择想要做什么，你们既可以做这个脑筋急转弯拼图，去重新排列这些形状，也可以戴上拳击手套去击打这个形状，或者戴上拳击手套去击打这个击打垫。”
another activity, but this time you get to choose which one you want to do and you can either do this brain teaser puzzle where you have to rearrange these shapes or you can put on some boxing gloves and hit this shapes, or you can put on some boxing gloves and hit this punching pad. And so in one of our studies we found that, if men braided hair, then they were much more likely to choose as their next task, the punching task. But if they braided rope, then most of them wanted to do the brain teaser. So this suggests that the ones who had done the hair braiding task felt emasculated and so they kind of wanted to restore their masculinity by punching something, by, you know, behaving aggressively.
所以在我们的一项研究中，我们发现，如果男性编了头发，那么他们更有可能在接下来的任务中选择击打任务。但如果他们编的是绳子，那么大多数人都会想去做脑筋急转弯。这表明，那些做过编发任务的男性感到了被阉割了男子气概（被娘化），所以他们某种程度上想要通过击打某个东西、通过表现出攻击性来恢复他们的男子气概。
There's something really funny about these studies, isn't there? Uh, sure. That's one of my favorite things about what I do is the kind of the creativity and kind of concocting these scenarios. I also want to be taken seriously so the findings aren't funny. The methods can be funny. To be sure, it's worth pointing out that societal messages that constrain men have often been developed by men. Jennifer's point is not that sexism doesn't play a role in shaping these behaviors. Her point is that men can be trapped by the gender roles that they themselves have authored. There's a way in which you can look at your work that you're doing, and sort of say in some ways you're drawing,
这些研究真的很有趣，对吧？当然。我对自己所做的事情最喜欢的一点就是那种创造力，以及凭空构想出这些情境。我也希望被认真对待，所以研究结果并不是搞笑的。方法可以是有趣的。可以肯定的是，值得指出的是，那些约束男性的社会信息往往是由男性自己制定的。詹妮弗的观点并不是说性别歧视在塑造这些行为中没有起作用。她的观点是，男性可能会被他们自己亲手构建的性别角色所困。在某种程度上，你可以审视自己正在做的工作，然后在某种意义上可以说是，
perhaps compassionate is sort of the wrong word, but you're drawing a more deeper understanding of why men behave the way they do, that is not just men behave the way they do because there is misogyny. Right, I guess I feel like I have compassion for anybody who kind of finds themselves stuck in a world that makes no sense to them.
也许“富有同情心”这个词不太恰当，但你对男性为什么会表现出他们那种行为有了更深层的理解，这不仅仅是因为男性表现出这种行为是因为存在厌女症。对，我想我对于任何发现自己陷入一个对自己毫无意义的世界的人，都会有一种同情。
So regardless of whose fault it is, I think that the struggle for status that men kind of are constantly feeling like they have to participate in, it sucks. Men worry what other men will think, what women will think, what they themselves might think. All this leads us back to Robert Vaughan's dilemma about whether to become a nurse. The precarious status of masculinity drives many men to see the profession as the equivalent of braiding hair with pink ribbons. Remember that clip from Meet the Parents?
因此，无论错在谁，我认为男性不断觉得自己必须参与的那种争夺地位的斗争，真的很糟糕。男性担心其他男性会怎么想，女性会怎么想，他们自己又会怎么想。这一切把我们带回了罗伯特·沃恩（Robert Vaughan）关于是否要成为一名护士的困境。男子气概的不稳定地位促使许多男性将这个职业等同于用粉红丝带编头发。还记得《拜见岳父大人》里的那个片段吗？
Not many men are professional, are they, Greg? No, Jack. Not traditionally. This idea is deeply woven into our culture. Think about all the jokes you've heard about male nurses. So then? You've heard them on friends. Nurse found a doctor, huh?
没多少男人做这个职业，对吧，格雷克？没错，杰克。传统上来说没有。这个想法深深编织在我们的文化中。想想你听过的所有关于男护士的笑话。所以呢？你在《老友记》里听过。护士找到了医生，是吧？
Kind of girl, isn't it? And even on shows about hospital life. Like how? Sorry, I can't remember if I mocked you yet for being a male nurse. And scrubs. She's embarrassed that she likes a nurse, and I really can't figure out why. Well, that's because you're doing a woman's job, son.
有点像女生的活儿，不是吗？甚至在关于医院生活的节目里也是如此。比如怎么样的？抱歉，我不记得我有没有因为你是男护士而嘲笑过你。还有手术服。她为自己喜欢一个护士感到尴尬，而我真的搞不懂为什么。嗯，那是因为你在干女人的活儿，孩子。
Have a good one. So if you're in Robert's shoes, is there a way to silence the voice in your head that says, this kind of work is emasculating. A woman's job. A woman's job. A woman's job, a woman's job, a woman's job. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is NPR.
祝你过得愉快。所以，如果你处在罗伯特的立场上，有没有什么办法能让你脑海中那个声音安静下来，那个声音说：这种工作是在消磨男子气概。女人的活儿。女人的活儿。女人的活儿，女人的活儿，女人的活儿。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是美国国家公共电台（NPR）。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. London, autumn, 1854. Word was spreading through the city. Thousands of British soldiers had died in a conflict 1500 miles away in Eastern Europe. The Crimean War. But these men were not killed in combat. What they were really dying of, which was of not of the wounds, but infectious disease. Historian Julie Fairman at the University of Pennsylvania
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。伦敦，1854年秋天。消息正在城市中传播。数千名英国士兵在1500英里外东欧的一场冲突中丧生。克里米亚战争。但这些人并不是在战斗中战死的。他们真正死于的，不是伤口，而是传染病。宾夕法尼亚大学的历史学家朱莉·费尔曼（Julie Fairman）
says Londoners were shocked to learn about the poor medical conditions in Crimea. One woman in particular felt called to action. She was wealthy from high society. Her name was Florence Nightingale. She was able to convince her friends, and she had friends in high places, to let her take a contingent of nurses to the Crimea to take charge of this hospital. In November 1854, she arrived at a war camp with a group of nearly 40 nurses.
表示，伦敦人震惊地得知克里米亚糟糕的医疗条件。特别是有一位女性感到自己有责任采取行动。她出身于上流社会，十分富有。她的名字叫弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔（Florence Nightingale）。她说服了她的朋友们——而且她在高层有朋友——让她带领一支护士队伍前往克里米亚接管这家医院。1854年11月，她带着近40名护士组成的团队抵达了战争营地。
She finds hospitals that are dark and they're dingy and there's no air and their soldiers lying on the ground crying out. It must have been horrendous. Florence Nightingale took charge bringing cleanliness and order to the medical camps. She focused on sanitation. She made sure that injured soldiers were fed. Back home she came to be seen as something of a trailblazer. When she returned to London, she established a world's first professional nursing school with
她发现医院昏暗、肮脏、没有空气，士兵们躺在地上哭喊。那一定极其可怕。弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔接管了医疗营地，带来了清洁和秩序。她专注于环境卫生。她确保受伤的士兵有饭吃。回到国内后，她被视为某种开路先锋。当她回到伦敦时，她创立了世界上第一所专业护士学校，
one type of student in mind. Women. This was a shift before the Crimean War, nursing was not seen as the exclusive preserve of women. Everybody was a nurse. Everybody took care of their family members. They took care of the children. They took care of the wounded in battle. And so the profession, in fact you don't even talk about profession, but the idea of providing care to people was pretty heterogeneous across men, women and others. But Florence Nightingale was convinced that nursing was not for men. As her methods spread to Australia, Canada and the United States, women came to dominate
心中只有一个类型的学生：女性。这是一个转变。在克里米亚战争之前，护理并不被视为女性的专属领地。每个人都是护士。每个人都照顾自己的家庭成员。他们照顾孩子。他们照顾战场上的伤员。因此，这个职业——事实上你甚至不会称之为职业，但向人们提供护理的想法在男性、女性和其他人之间是相当多元的。但弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔坚信护理不适合男性。随着她的方法传播到澳大利亚、加拿大和美国，女性开始主导
nursing. Men were pushed to the fringes of the field, limited to working in psychiatric wards. By the 1930s, men were only 2% of nurses in the United States. Even today, that number is only 10%. The idea of women being able to give that gentle, caring touch when they provided care was a really strong ethos throughout the nursing profession and the public. Of course, when you think about it, there's nothing inherently feminine about nursing.
护理行业。男性被推到了该领域的边缘，局限于在精神病房工作。到了20世纪30年代，美国的男护士仅占2%。即使在今天，这个数字也只有10%。女性在提供护理时能够给予那种温柔、关怀的触摸这一理念，贯穿了整个护理职业和公众。当然，仔细想想，护理并没有什么天生女性化的东西。
Florence Nightingale literally invented that idea and made it real. So if you could turn nursing from a genderless profession to one seen as exclusively female, can you make the clock turn backwards? To some degree, you can spin any job. This again, a psychologist, Jennifer Bossin. You could spin nursing as a very masculine occupation. It's dangerous. It's physically grueling. You don't really have to be that warm to be a nurse. It doesn't hurt. But, you know, so our stereotype of the nurse is one that almost you know you could modify that stereotype and turn nursing into a profession that does seem
弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔字面意义上发明了这个概念并将其变为现实。所以，如果你能把护理从一个没有性别之分的职业变成一个被视为女性专属的职业，你能让时光倒流吗？某种程度上，你可以重塑任何工作。这位是心理学家詹妮弗·博辛（Jennifer Bossin）。你可以将护理包装成一种非常具有男子气概的职业。它很危险。它在体力上极其折磨人。做护士其实不需要那么热情。虽然这也无伤大雅。但是，你知道的，我们的护士刻板印象是——你几乎可以修改那个刻板印象，把护理变成一个看起来
masculine or male appropriate As it turned out something along the lines of what Jennifer proposed was presented to Robert Wann Remember how when Robert got out of the Navy his father-in-law suggested he think about nursing as a profession. It's a...in the man field pays...pretty well. And it's stable. You work 12 hours shifts, three days a week. You can make it money at it. Robert didn't take his father-in-law's advice, but he did get a job at a hospital as a security
很有男子气概或适合男性的职业。事实证明，类似于詹妮弗所提议的想法被摆在了罗伯特·万恩（Robert Wann）面前。还记得罗伯特退伍后，他的岳父建议他考虑把护理作为一种职业吗？这是一个……在男人的领域里，薪水……相当不错。而且很稳定。你做12小时轮班，一周三天。你靠这个能赚钱。罗伯特没有听从他岳父的建议，但他确实在一家医院找到了一份保安的工作，
guard. And one day, he had to deal with two patients who were out of control. We had a couple guys who came into the emergency room who were high presumably on PCP. I don't remember what it was at the time. And they were just very belligerent fighting. There was blood all over the place. And they were had to be split up into different rooms. And so we're trying to attend to them. And when you actually asked to secure them in one of the rooms, what was the role that you were playing? Yeah, security were kind of there to have eyes on
有一天，他不得不处理两个失控的病人。我们有几个家伙来到急诊室，他们大概是吸了PCP（天使尘）。我不记得当时具体是什么了。他们非常蛮横，还在打架。到处都是血。他们必须被分开关在不同的房间里。所以我们在试图照顾他们。当被要求在其中一个房间里控制住他们时，你扮演的角色是什么？是的，保安的存在是为了监视情况，
and potentially hands on if we need to, to help control the situation. So I was there, and these guys both came out of their rooms that they were isolated into and just started fighting. And they actually locked themselves in one of the rooms and destroyed the room, did a couple thousand dollars worth of damage and blood everywhere on the ceilings and the nurses and us and the sheriffs were in the doctors are all holding them down and sedating and restraining and I was like, man this is pretty cool.
如果需要的话随时准备动手，以帮助控制局面。所以我当时在那儿，这两个家伙都从他们被隔离的房间里冲出来，开始打架。他们实际上把自己反锁在其中一个房间里，把房间砸得稀巴烂，造成了数千美元的损失，天花板上、护士身上、我们身上到处都是血，警长和医生们都在按住他们、给她注射镇静剂和约束他们，当时我想，天哪，这太酷了。
As much as it was potentially dangerous, the action that the nurses were seeing was pretty exciting for me. You think of nursing, you think of someone sitting at a bedside and being like, let me hold your hand and you see what it is realistically day to day and for me it was 180 degrees. Robert took his father-in-law's advice and enrolled in nursing school. Now it's not as if the old stereotypes about gender and nursing disappeared altogether, but Robert found ways to carve a path of his own. His wife Christine says that when he was a nursing school,
尽管这具有潜在的危险，但护士们所经历的行动对我来说相当令人兴奋。一提到护理，你就会想到某人坐在床边说：“让我握着你的手”，而当你看到它每天的实际情况时对我来说完全是180度的大转弯。罗伯特听从了岳父的建议，报名上了护士学校。现在，这并不是说关于性别和护理的旧刻板印象完全消失了，但罗伯特找到了开辟自己道路的方法。他的妻子克里斯蒂娜（Christine）说，当他在护士学校时，
he bonded with the handful of other men in the program. Four of his closest friends are men who went through the nursing school program with him, and that kind of bond that they build that brotherhood. Maybe it's a very kind of like military-esque that they were together, and so there's this common thread of like, we're the men united together in you know, in this space. He's now been in the field for more than a decade. He works in a cardiovascular unit.
他与项目中仅有的其他几个男人建立了联系。他最要好的四个朋友是一起经历护士学校项目的男性，他们建立的那种羁绊，那种兄弟情谊。也许这非常类似于军旅风格，因为他们曾在一起，所以有一种共同的线索，就像，我们是团结在一起的男人，在这个空间里。他从事这个领域已经有十多年了。他在心血管病房工作。
When you made the decision to become a nurse, did you tell your friends or family about this? I'm wondering if, did you have hesitation about doing this? Were there an awkward conversation where you sort of said, you know, I'm going to become a nurse and people look at you strangely. I thought I would. I thought I would get some, at least some jeering from guys that I knew, to be like, oh, you're going to be a nurse, you know. Oh, we always knew that you were in the closet or, you know, there's jokes about it while if you're a nurse then therefore you must be gay. It's surprisingly I did not get that. A lot of the guys that I was friends with and when I told them you know I'm gonna go into nursing they were like that's cool it's a good job it pays well. You. It's a good job. It pays well. You know, it's a job of service. You're helping
当你做出成为护士的决定时，你把这件事告诉你的朋友或家人了吗？我在想，你对此有过犹豫吗？有没有过那种尴尬的对话，就是你说，你知道的，我要去当护士，然后人们用奇怪的眼光看你？我以为会的。我以为我会遭到一些嘲笑，至少来自我认识的家伙们的嘲笑，比如，“哦，你要去当护士了。”或者，“哦，我们一直都知道你内心是个基佬”，或者，你知道的，会有这样的笑话：如果你是个护士，那么你一定是个同性恋。出乎意料的是，我没有遇到那种情况。当我告诉那些和我关系很好的朋友我要去学护理时，他们的反应是：“挺酷的，这是一份好工作，薪水很高。”你。这是一份好工作。薪水很高。你知道的，这是一份服务人的工作。你在别人
people and their time of need. And I don't think there's any better job out there as far as you literally get paid to help people in some of their worst moments and help them get better and heal and go home. And that for me, I get paid to do that. That's awesome. And I find something really interesting if I do say my husband's a nurse. People usually want to know if there's a specialty. Christine Wannessine people perform mental gymnastics. When she tells them about her husband's job.
最需要的时候帮助他们。而且我认为没有比这更好的工作了，因为你字面意义上是靠在别人最糟糕的时刻帮助他们、帮助他们好转、康复并回家而获得报酬。对我来说，我因为做这个而获得报酬。这太棒了。而且如果我说我丈夫是个护士，我发现了一件非常有趣的事。人们通常想知道是否有专业细分。当克里斯蒂娜·万恩（Christine Wann）向人们讲述她丈夫的工作时，大家会进行心理体操。
And sometimes when I said, oh, well, he works in cardiology, but it's like, oh, as if that's masculine, that's made it more masculine, nursing. And it's just a very interesting dynamic. I know he'll tell me stories just that he'll walk into a room and a patient will assume he's the doctor. And once they realize he's not,
有时当我说，“哦，嗯，他在心脏病学部门工作”，但感觉就像，“哦，好像这更男性化，这让护理变得更男性化了。”这是一种非常有趣的动态。我知道他会跟我讲一些故事，比如他走进病房，病人会默认他是医生。而一旦他们意识到他不是，
Robert says patients sometimes get uncomfortable. In fact, I just got that last week and you just go, oh, it's okay, if you don't want to mail, perfectly fine, we'll work with that. I can talk to the charge nurse and we'll get assignments to change around. And we'll make a note that you prefer female staff only. And did you do that?
罗伯特说，病人有时会感到不舒服。事实上，我上周刚遇到过这种情况，然后你会说，“哦，没关系，如果你不想要男护士，完全没问题，我们可以处理。我可以跟护士长谈谈，我们把分工调整一下。我们会做一个备注，说明你只喜欢女性员工。”你真的那样做了吗？
Did you say that? Oh, yeah, I said that. I always say it every time. If they have an issue and sometimes they go, no, no. It's fine. It's just I've never had a nurse before that was mail. And sometimes they're OK with it. And sometimes they do want to change.
你这么说了吗？哦，是的，我说了。我每次都这么说。如果他们有异议，有时他们会说，“不，不。没关系。只是我以前从来没遇到过男护士。”有时他们觉得可以接受。有时他们确实想换。
And it's just not a factor. I just want to spend a second talking about how you feel with these interactions. I understand that at a professional level you are you're happy to sort of say, you know, I'll accommodate your request and move on. But at some level this is, you know, someone is basically saying they don't want you to be their nurse. And isn't that a little hurtful? It's a little hurtful, especially when I find it somewhat hypocritical when they'll have a doctor is a male and they're present, they're doing the checks and it's very intimate but somehow as a nurse I'm male and that's a problem.
这根本不是个问题。我想花一秒钟谈谈你对这些互动的感受。我理解在职业层面上，你很高兴地去说，你知道的，我会满足你的要求然后继续前进。但在某种程度上，这就是，有人基本上是在说他们不希望你成为他们的护士。这难道不有点伤人吗？这确实有点伤人，尤其是当我发现这有点虚伪的时候，因为他们会接受男医生在场，男医生会进行检查，而且非常亲密，但不知怎么的，作为一个男护士，这就成了问题。
It doesn't make any sense to me. You go wait a minute. the doctor is a mail too. Somehow you have no issue with him. That is a mail nurse. You have an issue. It's contradictory. Nearly everyone agrees it's a good idea to have diversity in healthcare.
这对我来说毫无意义。你会想，等一下。医生也是个男的。不知怎么的，你对他就没有任何问题。而对于一个男护士，你却有问题。这太矛盾了。几乎所有人都认为在医疗保健中保持多样性是个好主意，
But Robert says there's a double standard when it comes to men in nursing. You know, you see women going into become doctors, they are, it's like, oh, it's great. It's a wonderful thing that they're going to this. And we want that, but the flip side of, you got more men going into nursing, there isn't the accolade of, oh my gosh, you are, it's great of you to be reaching out and overcoming these gender stereotypes and going into this profession. They just look at you go,
但罗伯特说，在对待男护士的问题上存在双重标准。你知道，你看到女性去当医生，人们会觉得，哦，太棒了。她们去做这个是一件了不起的事。我们希望如此，但反过来，当你看到更多的男性进入护理行业时，却没有那种赞誉，比如“天哪，你太棒了，你走出来克服了这些性别刻板印象并进入了这个行业”。他们只是看着你，心里想，
I guess you probably weren't smart enough to be a doctor. There was some things about Robert. I figured I couldn't get by just talking to him on the phone. So I went to meet him. You must be Robert. How are you? He's 5'10". He has a muscular frame and a shaved head with a goatee.
我猜你大概没有聪明到去当医生吧。罗伯特身上有一些特质。我觉得光靠在电话里跟他说是不行的。所以我去见了他。你一定是罗伯特。你好吗？他身高5英尺10英寸。他身材健硕，剃着光头，留着山羊胡。
I shadowed him as he exercised in his home gym. I think for him, when he was in nursing school, starting cycling with a group of other males going through nursing school was a starting point for him of like, I'm going to have my own equipment, I'm going to do this, I'm going to take care of my body and I'm going to do so very early in the morning and religiously while I was sleeping because I'm just still amazing. He wakes up at 4.30 in the morning to do these things. Do you tell you this?
我在他于家庭健身房锻炼时跟随拍摄。我想对 lubricants 他来说，当他在护士学校时，开始和一群也经历过护士学校的其他男性一起骑行，对他来说是一个起点，就像，“我要拥有自己的器材，我要这样做，我要照顾好我的身体，而且我会在清晨进行，雷打不动，而那时我还在睡觉，因为我实在太厉害了。”他早上4点30分起床做这些事。你跟别人说这个吗？
Today, he thankfully moved the session to 4.30 pm. Robert has set up a bunch of equipment in his garage. There's a bench, stacks of weights, dumbbells, a pull-up bar. My favorite things are the motivational messages plastered on the wall. One sticker says, Discipline equals freedom. Robert says it's from Jocco Willink. Jocco Willink, he's maybe he's on Twitter, he's quite popular but he has a method. It's a squat day, you have a push day, you have a lift day, and you have a pull day. As I listened to Robert,
今天，他谢天谢地把训练时间改到了下午4点30分。罗伯特在车库里安装了一堆器材。有一个长凳、成堆的哑铃、引体向上杠。我最喜欢的是贴在墙上的励志标语。其中一个贴纸上写着：“纪律等于自由”。罗伯特说这是杰科·维林克（Jocko Willink）说的。杰科·维林克，他可能在推特上很活跃，相当受欢迎，但他有一套方法。今天是深蹲日，明天是推举日，然后是举重日，还有引体向上日。当我听罗伯特说话时，
I couldn't help but remember the study that Jennifer Boston had conducted. When men are asked to braid hair, they compensate by punching bags to reclaim their lost masculinity. Could some of Robert's intense exercise regimen be connected to his job as a nurse? Could the sports truck he drives to work every day be a defense mechanism? Robert's intense exercise regimen be connected to his job as a nurse?
我不禁想起詹妮弗·博辛（Jennifer Bossin）做过的那项研究。当被要求给头发编辫子时，男性会通过打沙袋来补偿，以夺回他们失去的男子气概。罗伯特高强度的锻炼计划中，是否有一些与他作为护士的工作有关？他每天开去上班的那辆运动卡车，会不会是一种防御机制？罗伯特高强度的锻炼计划，是否与他作为护士的工作有关？
Could the sports truck he drives to work every day be a defense mechanism? I think a lot of guys who might go into healthcare are interested in health and fitness. And I think part of it may also be showing, hey, you know, I'm not this, I'm not sure the wording I'd want to use for it. I'm not a this nurse stereotype. It's maybe it's pushing against the stereotype of what you might assume a male nurse would be. And so it's saying, you know what, I'm not that. I'm actually pretty manly in other aspects. By Robert rejects the idea that his own fitness regime is a form of psychological compensation, he does see himself compensating in another area.
他每天开去上班的那辆运动卡车，会不会能算作一种防御机制？我想很多可能进入医疗行业的男生都对健康和健身感兴趣。我想部分原因也可能是在展示：“嘿，你知道的，我不是那种——我不知道该用什么词来表达这个。我不是那种护士刻板印象。”这也许是在抗拒你对男护士可能抱有的刻板印象。因此它是在说：“你知道吗，我不是那样的人。我在其他方面其实相当有男子气概。”虽然罗伯特否认他自己的健身计划是一种心理补偿形式，但他确实看到自己在另一个领域做出了补偿。
I've had patients where I've had them a couple of days, two, three days, and at first they were hesitant about having a male as a nurse and they would pull me aside as they're discharging home and they say, you know what, you were the best nurse the entire time I was here. I had a lot of female nurses and they were great, but you were actually more gentle and more caring because you are acutely aware of the fact that you're being judged in that manner. Robert was drawn to nursing because he saw the job as an extension of the identity he'd established in the military.
我曾遇到过这样的病人，我照顾了他们好几天，两三天，起初他们对于有男护士感到犹豫，但在他们准备出院回家时，他们会把我拉到一边说：“你知道吗，你是我在这里期间最好的护士。我有很多女护士，她们都很棒，但你实际上更温柔、更体贴，因为你敏锐地意识到你正以那种方式被评判。”罗伯特被护理吸引是因为他将这份工作视为他在军队中确立的身份的延伸。
When in his decade as a nurse, he's grown to admire the skills he once considered feminine. My thinking on this is evolved to the point where I can say men are still just as compassionate and empathetic. We just express that sometimes in a different way. Being a father, I have two kids. I don't love my kids any less than my wife does, but I show my love and my compassion, my empathy to my kids sometimes in a different way than my wife does. Is that your trampoline?
但在他当护士的十年里，他逐渐开始欣赏那些他曾经认为是女性化的技能。我对这件事的看法已经演变成这样：我可以断定，男性依然同样富有同情心和同理心。我们只是有时用不同的方式来表达。作为一个父亲，我有两个孩子。我爱我的孩子并不比我妻子少，但我对孩子的爱、同情和同理心，有时表达的方式与我妻子不同。那是你的蹦床吗？
My daughter, who's four, almost four, goes up to my mother and says, um, grandma, look at my muscles. I work out. Oh my gosh, what are these? Are these two-pound dumbbells? My daughter wakes up and she wants to do push-ups with me in the morning and she wants to eat my protein bar when I'm waking up in the morning. You know, the impact that I have on her, you know, is me being a role model for making her a strong independent woman. When policymakers talk about interventions to help the jobless find work, they talk about vocational schools and retraining skills. They don't talk about how, without anyone saying it allowed, one half of the population might be systematically excluding itself from the very parts of the economy that are booming.
我那四岁、快满四岁的女儿走到我妈妈跟前说：“嗯，奶奶，看我的肌肉。我有锻炼哦。”“天哪，这些是什么？这是两磅重的哑铃吗？”我女儿醒来后想和我一起在早上做俯卧撑，当我在清晨醒来时，她想吃我的蛋白棒。你知道，我对她产生的影响，你知道的，就是我通过做她的榜样，让她成为一个坚强独立的女性。当政策制定者谈论帮助失业者寻找工作的干预措施时，他们谈论的是职业学校和技能再培训。他们不谈论的是，在没有人明说的情况下，半数人口可能正在系统性地将自己排除在经济中蓬勃发展的那些部分之外。
Robert was reluctant to pursue nursing because of all the narratives about male nurses. Kind of girl, isn't it? Of course, there is another word for these emasculating jokes. They are stereotypes. When it comes to fighting stereotypes, we often imagine that the right approach is to explain why the stereotypes are wrong. But Robert's life suggests a different solution and perhaps a more effective one. Stereotypes are powerful because the stories we tell about ourselves are powerful.
由于关于男护士的种种非议，罗伯特最初很不愿从事护理工作。“有点像女生的活儿，不是吗？”当然，对于这些消磨男子气概的笑话，还有另一个词。它们就是刻板印象。在与刻板印象作斗争时，我们常常认为正确的方法是解释为什么这些刻板印象是错误的。但罗伯特的人生提供了一种不同的解决方案，或许也是一种更有效的解决方案。刻板印象之所以强大，是因为我们对自己讲述的故事是强大的。
They shape how we see the world and how the world sees us. But in the end, they are only stories. And stories? We can rewrite them. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Part Shah and Brent Bachman and edited by Tara Voil and Raina Cohen. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarral and Kimmelavarga Strastrepo. Special thanks to Maggie Penman and Andy Huthar. I'm Shankar Vitaanthum. See you next week.
它们塑造了我们如何看待世界，以及世界如何看待我们。但归根结底，它们只是故事。而故事？我们可以重写它们。本期《隐藏的大脑》由帕特·夏（Part Shah）和布伦特·巴克曼（Brent Bachman）制作，由塔拉·沃伊尔（Tara Voil）和雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）剪辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）、劳拉·夸拉尔（Laura Quarral）和金梅拉瓦尔加·斯特拉斯雷波（Kimmelavarga Strastrepo）。特别感谢玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）和安迪·胡瑟（Andy Huthar）。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 本集节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。